hello David hello Kim so I brought you
here to talk about the Gilded Age which
is one of my favorite eras of American
history because everything was great and
covered in gold no because it is the
only era of American history I can think
of that has a sarcastic name so what
what's what's to be sarcastic about
what's happening between so I see it's
from 1865 to 1898 which is the end of
the Civil War and then what happens in
1898 98 that's basically everyone woke
up one morning and they were like yeah
we're done with the Gilded Age now it's
time for the Progressive Era hurray
spanish-american war times more first
the spanish-american war so the Gilded
Age is kind of this period of really
intense industrialization kind of
focusing on America's development as an
industrial and business power very
inward looking whereas after the
spanish-american war the United States
takes a bigger role on the world stage
the the sarcastic part of the Gilded Age
is that this was a term coined by Mark
Twain of all people in 1890 and he wrote
a book called the Gilded Age and what
would twine was trying to say was that
the United States in this period wasn't
experiencing a golden age right an era
of prosperity and happiness but rather a
Gilded Age oh so just like a thin layer
of gold on top disguising the cheap tin
beneath exactly oh snap train so what's
going on in this era that earns this
nickname like what is what is the
appearance of you know fancy lovely gold
that just turns out to be tacky and
miserable well I think what people are
talking about under the title of Gilded
Age is that it's this time when immense
wealth is accumulated by a number of
individuals um you know many of whom
still have their names on things today
like Andrew Carnegie um Carnegie Mellon
University or Carnegie Hall JP Morgan
who was a banking magnate we still have
JP Morgan as a fine
Angell institution today and I would say
a john d rockefeller
is another he was the founder of
Standard Oil so he was an oil baron
Rockefeller Center right so these are
the individuals who got enormous ly
wealthy in the Gilded Age and they got
wealthy by being the captains of these
new expanding and industries items of
industry titans of industry so steel and
banking and oil but they got rich partly
through political corruption so one one
of the less than savory parts of the
Gilded Age is that a lot of this was
done through political kickbacks bribing
of officials bribing of the vice
president of the United States wait what
the bribe the vice president that was a
scandal that dogged the presidency of
ulysses s grant credit mobili a was a
construction company that had less than
savory ties to some people very high up
in government so this these fortunes of
people like Carnegie and Morgan were
built partly on political corruption and
partly on the backs of waves of
immigrant laborers like my ancestors
like my ancestors and so you know during
this time period in the eastern part of
Europe in the southern part of Europe
you know there were there were political
eruptions there were just general
poverty especially in Italy and in
Russia there are a number of pilgrims
which sent Russian Jews out of Russia
and they came to the United States and
you know they came from very bad
situations so what they came to was a
little bit better but it wasn't much
better which is how they all ended up
living in this one apartment in lower
Manhattan and as you've detailed in this
what is this a Jacob Riis photograph
right okay so Jacob Riis was a
photographer in the 1890s and he went
around the Lower East Side of
hatton basically just photographing what
he called how the other half lives um
and by the other half he meant
immigrants the poor who were living in
the Lower East Side of Manhattan which
at that time was the most dense section
of humanity on earth and you can see
here that this is a photograph from a
tenement that he took a picture of and
what is it what does a tenement so
tenements were these uh apartment
dwellings which kind of sprang up often
in the backyards of other normal
buildings but they were sort of hastily
constructed they had many rooms in them
they weren't up to fire code I'm not
even sure there was a fire code most of
the rooms didn't have windows or
electric lighting or ventilation it's
like a great place to live one thing
that doesn't have curb appeal Kim ah
there are some pictures that can show
you know most of them work next to giant
rotting heaps of garbage oh boy one of
my favorite things about the the story
of Jacob Riis is that he was a pioneer
in the field of photography because he
used flash photography so you know
you've seen in old movies those flash
bulbs that go off right because that was
the only way he could get these
apartments to do there was no lighting
in there there's no lighting in them so
you couldn't take a picture of them
without light so he brought his flash
camera and he regularly set things on
fire
these apartments as he was trying to
document what life was like so this this
is a photograph by Rhys called five
cents a spot and so you paid five cents
a night to live in this apartment and if
you count here there's one two three
four five six I think this is somebody
else's legs seven did I get everybody
there might be somebody else hiding over
here seven men sharing this room and
they're just you know doing the best
they can um and you compare that with
this which is john d rockefeller
mansion in New York it's called and I'm
going to butcher this [ __ ] it so the
real question of the Gilded Age is how
is it that some people get so wealthy
while some people are incredibly poor
sure and whose responsibility is that
right at one point so JPMorgan um
decides he's going to buy out Andrew
Carnegie
he buys him out for more than four
hundred million dollars he loans money
to the US government so he is like the
single biggest creditor to the US
government at that point who has more
power the federal government or JP
Morgan so we're really talking about the
the clash of like two great and terrible
energies right like this immense wealth
and this immense deprivation yeah how do
they play out we'll get to that in some
more videos